uh-oh I [ __ ] we were we went into
Best Buy and I was just like yeah [ __ ] I
want to get if I wanted to get like a
new coffee maker for the tour bus and I
walked on the island I see this [ __ ]
super souped up [ __ ] steering wheel
with foot pedals and I'm like man it'd
be kind of fun to [ __ ] be playing
race car on the tour bus while we're
driving around and then I learned in
order to use that [ __ ] steering wheel
you have to buy a console and I go oh my
God am I about to buy an Xbox video game
console it goes against everything you
[ __ ] did everything has team tests
I did it but I lost the cord the things
we were never able to use it what you
bought the whole console I bought a
console and the steering wheel
[ __ ] so that we could [ __ ]
race cars while we're driving down the
road for what game you don't even know
what game you got yeah
never even got it to work and sitting on
the tour bus just as a reminder that I
[ __ ] failed
there you go failing again that's just a
dumb thing uh yeah well that's cool but
video yeah video games like [ __ ] big
money if you're an actual like main
character yeah if you develop one did
you ever see there was like some big
video game contest this was like this
right before
for covet or whatever and it was like a
16 year old kid like beat out like 5 000
people playing like fortnite like
whatever one of those yeah and won three
million like he's like all right hey Mom
and Dad you now live at my house yeah or
like on Tick Tock you can see like some
of those [ __ ] smoking hot chicks that
are just on Twitch playing video games
making bank Jesus that's like the
biggest thing in [ __ ] YouTube maybe
not anymore but
and this is why I hate video games is
because I think that like it I think
that it's just a criminal waste of time
and energy and effort what do you mean
by like like you know criminal ways like
somebody who's in jail just plays me no
no I'm just let's say like you got
really good at a video game okay okay
where did that get you in life you know
like stuck on the couch that's what I
always said like uh you know like how
how does being good at video games get
you laid you know or get you paid you
know and I couldn't figure that out I'm
like okay so you're just putting a lot
of genuine work and time and effort into
something that's not gonna benefit you
in life well now people on Twitch are
getting paid and late right
dude there's some [ __ ]
then came the phenomena people wyling
away
you hours of their life watching videos
of other [ __ ] playing video games
yeah I mean my cousin's watching like
Minecraft like people like playing and
talking about like narrating their own
experience I saw I was on an American
Airlines flight I think or some European
play and uh in their little video on
demand library of the airplane there was
a documentary called our video games
really dangerous or dude does video game
violence lead to real life violence and
I thought ooh that's uh an interesting
topic you know like I watched the whole
thing and they said uh basically to
paraphrase with the whole takeaway was
was that there is no link between video
game violence and real life violence but
there's a huge link between like uh
playing video games and being a complete
[ __ ] loser
I think that that's why Americans are
fat and [ __ ] lazy and unmoted me
because they're not getting outside and
exercising they're sitting on the
[ __ ] couch playing stupid video games
yeah I wonder why that is I mean you
grew up in Germany no I think I grew
like Summers and stuff there it's I
don't they ride bikes everywhere but
here here oh speaking of that I when I
was a kid my bike was my freedom like
you rode everywhere and then my
skateboard was the next one yeah you
know but before my skateboard was my
bike like you got out of the house and
you rode your friend's house for sure
rode and went to the beach with your
friends and stuff it was Freedom no joke
I was at a clothing company the other
day and they had like a hundred of the
same little kid bikes they're like ones
that they don't even have pedals it's
that kids use to like pedal like with
their feet and then they had a couple
bigger ones and we're like hey what
what's with the bikes like why so many
this isn't even what you do like and
they were like we donate these to
schools
for PE and stuff and the lady goes do
you know that right now in the states
eighty percent of Youth young kids and
all that don't know how to ride a bike
wow 80 I thought you were gonna say 80
of Americans born after year 2000 will
develop type 2 diabetes but it's not 80
it's like it's like 33 is it no but no
they don't they don't even ride bikes
and it is past 2002 to 2000 because
right now
2001 is when 21 year olds are were born
right isn't that crazy 2001. somebody
was born in 2001 is 21 this year that's
when I graduated high school yeah I mean
people are riding like electric scooters
now like they're not yeah they don't
even they don't even use power I mean
dude like the diabetes is so gnarly and
like
I forget what the actual number is but
it's
I think one in three I think one in
three Americans one and three because if
it is thirty seven thirty five percent
I saw that statistic one in three
Americans born after year two thousand
will develop type 2 diabetes one and
three that's how [ __ ] awful the the
nutrition the and the physical therapy
like PE physical education no exercise
shitty diet just go to school and play
on your computer sit on your [ __ ]
stuff on your [ __ ] phone and don't
exercise and eat dog [ __ ] I think that
clip was awesome but not as awesome is
my new book a hard kick in the nuts what
I've learned from a lifetime of terrible
decisions my first books Five star rated
on Amazon and I have no doubt this one
will be too so get the autograph copy
right now at stevo.com
yeah dude